vous avez dû le constater ces derniers
jours le temps n'est pas nécessairement
de la partie et pourtant il faut penser
à entretenir son jardin et donner de
l'attention à ces plantes le mois de
mars et nous avons propice à l'entretien
des rosiers quelques conseils pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la main verte
pour cela je l'accueille en plateau avec
moi mais à l'époque et bonsoir à mélanie
si on sort flora valeur avant de faire
la taille de ces roses et il faut savoir
le type que l'on possède
parce que chacun demande une taille
particulière il y en a trois types de
rezé lé grimpant les buissons et les
couvre-sol la taille se prépare en deux
étapes avant l'hiver il faut notamment
faire un nettoyage pour sélectionner les
branches enlever celles qui sont déjà
trop faible c'est la taille de mars par
contre qui la plus importante qu'elle
permet aux roses et de se renforcer de
faire réapparaître de nouvelles branches
france au moulin et l'ancien responsable
du potager du roi de versailles il nous
explique comment tailler les rosiers
d'antan et les buissons pour les rosés
grimpa en conserve les branches
principales ont fait un renouvellement
annuel
et puis les petites branches secondaires
sont taillés coupé à deux yeux à deux
bourgeons
quant aux rosiers buissons même époque
bien sûr on prend soin d'eux d'avoir un
buisson à errer garder 4 5 belles
branches et que l'on coupe qu'on l'on
redescend à 2,3 bourgeon en prenant soin
de conserver détaillées sur des
bourgeons qui regarde vers l extérieur
alors là l'image qu'on va voir c'est la
taille des rosiers grimpants alors pour
le tailler faut à chaque fois à faire
des coupes franches qu'elle soit bien
propre et bien-être
avoir un bon sécateur qui est bien
aiguisé et propre ça évite d'abîmer la
plante il faut c taillée à chaque fois 2
à 3 mm au dessus du dernier bourgeon il
ne faut pas oublier de couper tous les
projets qui viennent du sol parce que ça
vient des racines ça peut abîmer aussi
là le rosier pour le rose exemple il
faut aussi penser à attacher
régulièrement les branches pour qu'ils
prennent ils prennent une belle forme et
ne pas oublier linceul et
l'ensoleillement de la plante
parce que c'est aussi très important
pour sa formation alors on a parlé de la
taille mais il n'y a pas que ça qui
compte mais la vidéo si l'entretien à
faire il n'y a pas qu'au mois de mars
convoi s'occuper de ces plantes tous les
plants de son rejet de son rosé parce
qu'il peut être planté dans un jardin il
peut te poser dans un peloton
impôts sur un balcon ça demande beaucoup
d'entretien il faut aussi éviter les
intérieurs ce que je disais tout à
l'heure ça a besoin de lumière ça besoin
d'humidité
cette fois je vous propose de vous
rendre chez marianne donné elle est
fleuriste à saint cyr l'école au mois de
mars est bien de faire un apport
d'engrais
donc on la taille justement on fait un
apport d'engrais qu'on va renouveler fin
avril au niveau du pied après tout au
long de l'année notamment la conte les
beaux jours arrivent bien nettoyer le
pied du rosier puisque les rosiers aime
bien avoir les pieds toujours bien
propre au moment de la floraison
il est important de veiller à bien
arrosée sont haussiers c'est quand même
une plante qui a besoin d'un arrosage
régulier
alors on a parlé des rosiers mais mois
de mars est aussi l'occasion de prendre
soin de son jardin dans sa globalité
c'est aussi un mois propice aux semis
pour donner peut-être vie à votre
potager
oui puisqu'on peut en effet planté les
variétés précoces des pommes de terre
des roses d'oignons blancs ou encore das
perche de petits pois et 2 carottes
on peut même faire des semis sous abri
comme celle de la salade de choux de
bruxelles ou encore de la betterave
vous pouvez aussi travailler votre
verger même s'il faut le dire nous
sommes à la fin au mois de mars celle
des pommiers et des poiriers sa touche
déjà à sa fin
hank deux fois président de
l'association jardins passions partage à
guyancourt
elle nous a reçus chez à la sionge dans
son jardin vient nous donne encore
quelques petits conseils à partir de
mois de mars on commence à nettoyer un
peu à faire un pas de vis dedans
lorsqu'il reste raconter tout ce qui
reste dans le potager par exemple les
ports ou des
et des betteraves puis après la bourre
et un peu la terre surtout avec la
grelinette on retourne pas vraiment la
terre autour d'un petit paumé pas
renverser voilà vous connaissez
maintenant quelques astuces pour
améliorer votre rosier et votre jardin
si vous voulez découvrir d'autres
astuces de jardinage l'association
jardins passions partage propose un
atelier ce samedi au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux le sujet
de ce samedi ce sont les plantes
tolérantes à la sécheresse
merci